Sometimes the questions we come up with in this class are a little bit contrived,
but this one is actually practical.
Let's say your spaceship crashes onto a strange planet. It could happen to you.
It could happen to you. You'll want to know what to do.
At first you're not too happy, because you don't know where you are,
but then you see this strange tree over here with the vine dangling from one of the branches.
This makes you happy, because now you think, hey,
I can make a pendulum out of this and perhaps by doing that,
I can somehow figure out what the acceleration due to gravity is
on this strange planet.
To make this into a pendulum, you tie your space backpack filled with space weights
down at the bottom of this vine, which by the way has a length of 12 m.
Your goal is to find little g--the acceleration due to gravity on the surface of this strange planet.
What you do is you pull this back by a small amount and let it swing
back and forth and back and forth.
You time this swinging, and when you let it swing back and forth 10 times,
you find it takes 45 seconds.
I want you to tell me what is little g, the acceleration due to gravity,
and you can enter your answer here in seconds.